y'all don't need to put that in my
wikipedia like that defines me
that's crazy i'm about to call my
manager up this is
wild this is not okay yo what up gq this
is amine and i'm going undercover on the
internet
this is actually me
first up let's check out reddit
fun fact all three singles have featured
the album title he was hinting at the
title since shimmy
shimmy right at the beginning of the
single you hear distorted limbo
riri stuck in limbo for how long
compensating also features the distorted
limbo as an ad
yes uh peep my mixtape i will not be
peeping your mixtape but you are very
right and i did that on purpose
there's a limbo distorted like tag that
we've been using throughout the album i
can't wait to use that tag on tour
once we can go on tour that's definitely
how we're gonna start the shows
i'm glad you noticed that you do certain
things on purpose
and when you guys notice them it feels
good
i didn't know that my first reddit
comment that i would read about myself
would be so nice
so thank you next
[Music]
that beat switch in the middle of the
song was real smooth
love that transition i'm sure this will
have an eccentric video attached to it
soon haha
eddie anyone know who the female
vocalist was in the middle
or was that a sample we worked really
hard on that song in its transitions
quick little background story i've had
riri
in my laptop for a year and a half
i made that before i even made 1.5 i
think so i saved that for the album
because i knew i really liked the song
we got joyce rice and marshay black from
portland
to sing on the bridge and those are two
like actual friends of mine who sing
amazing so i knew that the song had this
like very rough
feel to it and it was really turned and
i really wanted to make sure that the
song kind of got its own break
the song like pretty break that kind of
like takes you to heaven and then brings
you back down
to earth so that's what it was supposed
to feel like glad you noticed the key
achilles
all right now let's check out my
wikipedia
amine was born and raised in northeast
portland neighborhood of woodlawn he
grew up wanting to play basketball but
was cut from the benson polytechnic
basketball team freshman sophomore year
i don't know why
that's in like my bio on wikipedia
that's not information everybody needs
to know that's so embarrassing
yeah i told people i got cut and that's
fine but y'all don't need to put that in
my wikipedia like that defines me
that's crazy i'm about to call my
manager up this is wild this
is not okay if i didn't get cuffed from
the basketball team
i wouldn't be sitting here with gq today
submit
all right let's check out twitter
our outcast and amine is singing about
the same
caroline definitely not they were
singing kind of like they don't really
[ __ ] with that caroline and i think mine
is kind of
uplifting or talking about a girl i like
first time i ever heard that name was
from outcast i had
never known anybody named caroline
caroline is just like an idea
of a person i'm talking about like
multiple women in that song not just one
how come in the song spice girl amina
mentions every spice girl except baby
spice
that's [ __ ] up with hella question
marks you need to chill out baby bug
bear because you're coming at me crazy
i forgot to put baby spice in there but
i know
the word baby is somewhere in the song
is
baby spice not in there or is she
actually you should go read the lyrics
on genius and
maybe she might be mentioning there and
you just didn't notice
replied yes i'm posting this on every
social media
i have but amine has scary spice in his
spice girl video
how am i meant to be calm question mark
exclamation point question mark
exclamation point at
heyamine that's my twitter by the way
when i came out with the
song spice girl scary spice was really
kind enough to
want to be in the video and she was down
to do the skit you took her bloopers
from the script i wrote for her to say
we just cut it up together in the spice
video and it ended up being really cool
i never would have thought that scary
spice would be in a music video of mine
or i would ever even really meet them i
have a lot of women in my family who
were in love with the spice girls they
just taught me
kind of who they were and i became a fan
as well
scary was actually my second favorite
because i love scary but
my favorite spice girl of all time was
sporty well i had a crush on her growing
up as well and now her and me are
friends i met her she came out to my
london show she's amazing
let's check out youtube
can someone tell me why people are so
hurt over him
creasing a hundred dollar af1 i thought
everyone liked to beat forces into the
ground well
my brother great tusker you must be
white
because in black culture we do not beat
up our forces that is a flex to beat up
your forces i don't crease my shoes i
used to walk around in middle school my
brand new jordans are af ones without
ever
bending my foot me creasing the air
force one was just
a big flex ruining something that people
hold
valuable you know what i'm saying it's
like it's nothing just throw it in the
bag
how do you walk without increasing them
uh you kind of walk
like a you have a peg leg you know
saying you walk really
crazy when you got your new shoes that's
what we used to do in the early 2000's
you know we held jordan's like
very close to us you know shout out to
michael jordan
[Music]
next
how many beautiful black women would you
like amine aminae
yes yeah there's a ton of beautiful
black women in riri they all did it from
their house
quarantine social distancing remember to
stay six feet
away actually most of the women in the
review video were all friends of mine
and then two or three of them we casted
joyce rice who sings on the bridge is in
the beginning in the middle
she's all over the video and then
marshay black who
sings a little bit on the bridge as well
is in the video
she's the girl sipping the orange juice
that's all i got for you nikhil
and anth i don't want to disrespect your
family but your last name is hella hard
to say
just like mine though so cool
[Music]
why nobody is talking about the way he's
his own photographer
yeah we were in this uh editing room for
like five days straight trying to make
riri
and edit review together and we had that
scene
and i was supposed to be rapping towards
the camera and that was the scene but
we just made that decision off the cuff
so i was just like it'd be really cool
to see myself
photograph myself that wasn't even in
the treatment for the video
we just decided that on the spot a lot
of scenes from like a lot of my music
videos kind of
happen on set as well
[Music]
bruh issa rae in this video yeah
uh issa rae is a good friend of mine she
is a sweetheart and she was
super nice and kind enough to want to be
in a video of mine
she showed up and played my baby mama
and she played it very well yeah it was
definitely like
really cool to have her early on in my
uh music video before anyone else
so that was cool me and issa kind of
have been friends since
the good for you era she tweeted about
the good for you album when it came out
but yeah ever since then we've been
friends and
that led to you know me being uninsecure
and then
she's just like a really good person
let's see
what people are saying on instagram
sofia said
scary spice and she commented that on a
selfie of mine in my new hairdo i forgot
that scary spice actually did that
when i decided to do that to my hair for
the album cover
we just wanted to pick something that
really was different and i had never
done bantu knots my hairstylist
aliki who usually does my braids put
together the
my hair when i looked in the mirror and
i was like oh this is really sick
so i just decided to go with it because
i liked it
simple as that definitely is a happy
coincidence
where's the damn album and the skincare
routine
y'all got to stop complimenting me too
much on my skin because like my skin is
not that amazing but it is you know i
mean i'd be moisturizing there's a
makeup artist on set so
i definitely look better on camera than
i do in real life i think everyone does
but the damn album got announced after
review so
dvd kllm i hope you're happy once
limbo comes out august 7th replied
that's it for today shout out to gq much
love
peace